[Music]
Kim Kardashian's not a regular mom she
is a cool mom a cool mom who just joined
tick-tock it's really lit and fun and
crazy
the reality star just shared this video
of her and her six-year-old daughter
North
[Music]
yep that's Northey pressing the record
button and if you thought Kim was just
going to chill out in the background
think again
Kim busted out some pretty serious moves
dancing around to Bamba stereos to my
love guys this is a pretty big deal
Kim essentially vowed never to dance in
public again after her stint on Dancing
with the Stars in 2008 yeah remember
that I'm like a notorious non dancer
anyway that's super cute mommy-daughter
clip might just be the first of many tik
toks to come for North and Kim we do
lots of tik toks together when et caught
up with Kim and her hubby Kanye West
earlier this month the beauty mogul
admitted that she and her little girl
have their own private tick tock account
I want to ask you I know that you're the
biggest thing on social media do you see
do you ever tick-tock I do North has a
private tick tock account
we do lots of tic TOCs together and she
puts them in drops she's not allowed to
post them but we have lots of tic TOCs I
might post one soon oh and we are so
thankful that soon is now these two
really are the cutest little peas in a
pod and North seems to be following in
both her famous parents footsteps she's
a Gemini says she's a little bit of both
she definitely has Kanye's outgoing
personality and will say whatever is on
her mind no matter what it is or who it
might offend and then she's also really
common sweet like me sometimes and she
might just take over her Mama's biz one
day is she a beauty mogul in the making
will she take over for you one day you
know I actually had to put her on our PR
list and get her her own set of makeup
this time because she destroys all of
mine when she sees it and then I can't
use it for myself so she she definitely
loves makeup if she loves it enough she
can definitely take it over whatever she
wants to do when she is old enough she
can do but her new favorite thing ever
is no one in the room no adults closing
the door with one of her friends or her
dolls and doing makeovers and no one can
see until the final look is done or
she'll freak out and cry and you know
North loves a before-and-after she loves
it before-and-after it is only a matter
of time before the next generation of
Kardashian's is running the show and
something tells me North will be leading
that pack of course you can count on et
to bring you all the latest on Kim and
North so make sure to keep it locked
right here until next time I'm Hallie
Stevens see you soon
[Music]